Ah yes, exellent, so heute basteln wir mal wieder was, allerdings diesmal nicht fürs
Fenster, sondern für Weihnachtsbaum, das am Fenster, das am Fenster habe ich euch ja
schon gezeigt wie das mittlerweile ausschaut, wobei ich glaube ich habe gar kein Video davon
wie es aktuell ausschaut, ich habe auf Twitter nur diese Sache gepostet am Fenster, genau
das habe ich ja auf Twitter gepostet, wo man das LED-Gedöns am Fenster sieht, aber ich
habe ja so Diffusor-Dinger mittlerweile noch drum, dass es nicht so grell ist an den einzelnen
LEDs, ne, so, und heute basteln wir nichts fürs Fenster, streamen erstmal ein bisschen
Werbung, gucken damit der Max was verdient, exquisite, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen
Plastenschirm, ich guck mal ob ich das sehe, ich guck mal ob ich das sehe, wieviel ich
verdiene, das gibt es im Creator Dashboard, wieviel ich verdiene, wieviel ich verdiene
an Ads, das würde mich echt mal interessieren, wo sieht man das denn, ah Moment meine Bitrate
ist auch viel zu hoch, wartet mal, Output ist das ne, Bitrate ist viel zu hoch, das kann
kaum einer gucken, bam, Bitrate geht gar nicht runter, excellent, warum geht die Bitrate
nicht runter, vielleicht kann das der Nvidia-Decoder nicht, on the fly, das Ding, ich mach mal ein
bisschen runter, weil für den Desktop brauchen wir beim besten Willen keine 8 MBit, ich mach
mal, ich bin in 10 Sekunden wieder da, ich mach mal aus und wieder an, dass auch, dass
mehr Leute zugucken können, weil Internet in Deutschland und so, ihr wisst ja, ne.